go
today we're trying out something a bit
more extreme we are playing table tennis
in the middle of this lake
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so here begins our building
process here's the raft it's going to be
about 6.7 meters long yeah it's going to
be a quite a big raft let's start
building so we have four of these
floatings
and now we are going to
connect the first two
[Music]
okay and this is our construction
manager becca he's nice to meet you too
he's got it all planned out and we we
trust that his measurements are correct
and helping helping us here is
patrick
this is going to be the middle part now
coming next
oh
mika is trying to learn how to use the
tool
maybe we should uh start a construction
youtube channel maybe i like building
confinition so yeah we have to pull it a
bit more to the uh lake so we get some
more space to build it over there
[Music]
further further so this is the lane
come on
[Music]
faster
let's go let's go let's go
[Music]
so this is it
this this thing is big
does it matter if it gets wet remember
we're going to take it in the middle of
the railing
starting to look like something yeah
how are you gonna film from there you're
gonna film i'm just gonna go
bye m is trying to run away go around
the island
we're out here in the middle of a lake
building a raft
just so we could get videos for you so
do us a favor and hit subscribe do it
now
okay so we've started building a floor
otto and becca
i think we are going to run out of wood
i've been doing this for like uh 15
minutes i know what i'm doing
[Music]
i don't know it's going to be our new
training hall
yeah i'm outside training hall so we're
going to start training here in the in
the middle of the lake
i think yeah we're wrapping things up
here we're gonna continue tomorrow
finishing the raft okay so it's day two
of
building the raft
it is
it's starting to look okay let's finish
this thing so we're sort of using
whatever we find how's the grip
[Music]
it's good with these sandals the grip
ain't the best
i hope i will not end on the bloopers
section
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
checkpoint patrick
[Music]
in the water
[Music]
so
soon it's gonna be coming up right after
this then we put a commercial break here
four out of four yeah
we're drilling the supports onto the
raft so the table won't wobble around so
they look like that
[Music]
if there's some people sitting
in the middle of the lake what are they
gonna think like a table tennis table
and a wrap in the middle of the lake
yeah the final piece of the castle yeah
and guys there we go
the raft is ready
now take a look at that
it's quite good
[Applause]
full speed
[Music]
[Music]
i want
[Music]
picking up the balls
it's so incredible to be here really
[Music]
a first person gopro playing in the
middle of the lake
[Music]
i can't wait to play on this yeah
[Music]
oh
pretty nice thanks
[Music]
the landscape is so incredible here
okay now the raft is actually underwater
yeah we have a bit of a flood situation
i don't think it's a problem
[Music]
this is how you train footwork on a
summer holiday
oh sorry
[Music]
okay so we're gonna do a pongfinity
diving shot tournament
though on the comments whose dive was
the best so i'm gonna try to do
uh between the legs and try to get it on
table emma's the first one to go
ready set go
oh
that wasn't too bad actually it was a
good try
[Music]
ready set go
i was expecting you to jump far
[Music]
my fault that was complete
go
go
that was close
go
it's a bit tiring to swim man
jump on board again and jump out again
i'm scared
at least you have to give the style
points
come on
now we'll see what the sensor can do
yeah
ready set
go
that's really close
that's how you do it you still got three
left
i got you a pedro one yeah it wasn't a
roller
coaster
okay he wanted to make it deep so dead
he tried to hit me
oliver the sea lion
it won't take long until optos picked up
all the balls
here he comes
you're welcome thank you
okay guys i think it's time to take
right back home
remember to subscribe and watch our
previous episodes there until next time
[Music]